Donald Trump received endless freak
media coverage from countless corporate
media outlets including CNN and yeah now
Trump has picked the fight with CNN
their fake news is retweeting memes blah
blah blah blah blah but it's getting
from personal grudges to possible
completely inappropriate meddling in
business decisions of the Justice
Department CNN's parent company Time
Warner wants to merge with AT&T and
there's lots of really good reasons to
be concerned about that right vertical
integration media consolidation we've
talked about many of the issues that
could impact consumers as a result of
that merger who decides whether the
merger will be approved well it's the
Justice Department currently run by Jeff
Sessions there are so many legitimate
reasons why this merger maybe shouldn't
be approved
what will the effective impact be on
competition in cable TV and the Internet
service provider industry so many
reasons why this is a concerning merger
it is now been reported that the White
House is discussing a potential point of
leverage on their adversary CNN the
pending merger the long and short of it
is that the White House is threatening
that if CNN continues to do the type of
coverage of the president that they
don't like maybe they'd get involved and
make it so that the time warner AT&T
merger does not happen this is so
ridiculous on so many levels not the
least of which that decisions about
mergers of this magnitude should be made
on the merits they should be made on the
basis of whether it would be
monopolistic what the impact would be on
consumers and to take a personal grudge
from The Oval Office into consideration
is absolutely and utterly ridiculous it
is also ridiculous because nobody was
even thinking about this merger which
would obviously be damaging to consumers
until now and now the focus is whether
CNN is or isn't fake news which should
have no bearing whatsoever on the merger
and of course I'm sure CNN will come out
strongly and say that the White House's
threats will have no impact on how they
choose to do the reporting what news
stories they choose to cover but it
obviously does even if it does so 10 to
20% because they have time warner in
their ear and that's that goes to a
larger point of self-censorship in the
trump era and autocracy and autocracy
everyone is dismissing this idea
recently that Trump might become an
autocrat because people are like well
he's not going to seize power in a
bloody coup he's not going to put
political dissidents in prison this is
modern authoritarianism which is both
insidious and effective and it can
happen through the bureaucratic
apparatus you don't have to imprison or
repress dissidents you just make them
irrelevant and this type of media
manipulation the attacks on media
outlets it is all this modern way of
imposing limitations on free speech and
you know what we've been talking about
YouTube ad pocalypse and how it's
affecting us this is part of why this
could not be this is the worst possible
time for a reduction in the number of
media voices and that's why we've been
talking about the issues that are
affecting us and other independent media
outlets and we will continue to
sickening absolutely sickening I'm out
of time for the voicemail I've got a
great voicemail but I'll play it for you
tomorrow I also don't have time to tell
you what's on the bonus show today but
it's all good stuff tremendous stuff
what folks believe me today's sponsor is
taga dab the hosting specialist whatever
your hosting needs for your business or
project taga dab can do it dedicated
servers virtual private servers cloud
server solutions colocation custom
server solutions and the big thing at
taga dab is there customer support over
70% of their business comes from repeat
orders and recommendations from existing
customers this is a testament to the
great support that they give their
customers currently rated a nine point
seven out of ten according to the
Trustpilot
review system with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab currently offers our viewers
and listeners a twenty british pound
free credit about twenty four US dollars
to all new customers that sign up gives
you a chance to try the service this is
a limited availability offer for the
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show to take advantage
Oh to sign up CagA Deb calm /t DPS and
use the offer code TDPS 20 during
account registration support our
sponsors and support our show in doing
so sign up ta ga da be calm /t DPS
coupon code is TDPS 20